[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis danseur d'interviews sérieux je
serai derrière comme dans ses pattes ou
plus moi ce que j'aime
bon ben ça donne mais fish m'a dit
prends le film que j'allais me fais pas
chier il ya eu des conneries qui ont été
dites dans l'émission que je regarde pas
la tp mp ouvert à tous
galy berda qui a dit n'importe quoi s
attendre avant de poser studio voulait
votre chaise et puis arrête de m'appeler
comme si tu as plein serveurs les maple
disent tout ouais moi j'aime bien les
mecs qui me pourrir tout ça mais c'est
qu'ils pêchent en soirée c'est le mec
ténébreux c'est le mail mystérieux
j'aimerais qu'ils ont retrait comme as
et qui fait que d'être des cobayes non
encore plus vite
il ya toujours le mec eh bien il fait
rigoler la main et à la fin on se moque
arrive pour faire bouger de l'art in il
va pas parler de la soirée mon père
ouais c'est lui qui parle ça va aller ça
mais arrêtez je connais bien il est
arrivé souvent ça dure malheureusement
oui
quand est élue miss france c'est l'enfer
bam
on te mets là quoi le faire tu rentres
dans une peugeot 306 mais tu es parti
rumba ou l'attaqué de pas la foire aux
saucisses quand même assez régulièrement
non tu vois plus personne serait
téméraire t'appelles tu crois que c'est
pour une fois revu ma passion d'amour et
à la devenu un adieu les chroniqueurs et
les promotions de merde je peux vous
l'annoncer aujourd'hui a dit non aux
caisses place l'animal n'est plus
et vous avez chaud sinon ça va chier
ouais j'ai bu un peu je me dis aux
téléspectateurs reprenons j'ai une
nouvelle manière de bois fait le che
bourgade et ne sera assez fort mais
finalement on s'attache
oui alors qu'à un moment les anneaux na
waie génial parce que ces canettes en
effet c'est rare chez les animaux qu'ils
étaient capables d'en faire un peu trop
un animal qui ont fait une descente
tu as
et
et tu chantes chantes chantes
c
qui dit une musique sans accord majeur
c'est une piste sans danseurs situe en
jeu dans ces moments là donc la carte
des idées noires les notes pourront se
dansait et nous reviendrons les chanter
[Applaudissements]
l'animal est toujours là
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce